we have been talking about sport of
American football and its connection to
severe brain disease for a very long
time chronic traumatic encephalopathy
also known as CTE is a degenerative
disease discovered in the brains of many
former professional players the NFL and
NFL officials officially have never
admitted that a link exists between
playing football and CTE even though
it's been abundantly clear for a really
pretty long time according to the
medical community it can't be
definitively diagnosed until after death
but over time we've seen especially uh
after the untimely deaths of younger and
younger football players for other
reasons right a car crash or or for
other reasons we've seen evidence of CTE
in autopsies even if teenagers Louis as
we've talked about in the past so the
connection has really been clear for a
while has it not it has and while while
the cause of death is not the CTE itself
right this can cause severe depression
and it can cause erratic behavior
violent behavior and several players
have committed suicide as a result of
the brain damage now the NFL has
maintained they're doing everything they
can to make football as safe as possible
they take safety very seriously but this
has never really addressed the true
issue even with better and better
helmets right the NFL always says we've
got the safest helmets we've ever had
that's fine in terms of preventing
concussion but CTE is related to the
cumulative impact of these
sub-concussive hits one after another
after another they're just part of
football and the big news is now for the
first time a senior NFL official has
acknowledged that there is a connection
between football and CTE his name is
Jeff Miller he's the NFL senior vice
president for health and safety and he
is admitted yes there is a link this was
during a roundtable discussion on the
issue of football-related head trauma
which was organized by the US House of
Representatives Committee on Energy and
Commerce and congresswoman jan
Schakowsky a Democrat from Illinois who
has been a guest on our show before
directly said to Miller is there a link
between football and degenerative brain
disorders like CTE and even though he
eventually sort of equivocated uh the
answer was yes from Jeff Miller the
answer to that question is certainly yes
he cited research by doctor and mckee
who's a brain injury specialist who
found signs of CTE in 90 out of 94
deceased NFL players 45 of 55 college
players and 6 out of 26 high school
students this might seem completely
uncontroversial to you and the content
of it is because we've known about the
dangers of football in CTE for a very
long time but just this year dr. Mitch
Berger who's a member of the NFL's head
neck and spine committee said there is
no link so the fact that we now have
Jeff Miller on record even though after
he said well you know there's a number
of questions we sort of have to look at
a blah blah blah blah blah he did say
yes there is a link it had to happen
eventually yeah that there was no way
they could deny this forever as as more
evidence piles up on them and so I guess
some for some reason they decided that
now was the time have you noticed that
when you watch football on TV there's
essentially no mention of this by
broadcasters I mean this is a crisis
right this is a crisis high school and
college football players clearly are
already suffering the effects of CTE you
could watch up every the full season of
football games you would not see it and
the reason is we don't really have
independent sports journalism
broadcasting games you might think we do
right Oh CBS is broadcasting the games
they can say whatever they want oh no
these TV contracts are huge money for
the networks and I don't know I don't
pretend to know whether it's implicit or
explicit but they don't want to lose
access the networks to broadcasting NFL
games and they're going to keep their
mouth shut about the fact that this is a
systemic problem for football players
yeah they're not going to address that
live on air but you cannot you you
cannot uh skip addressing when some
players lying unconscious on the field
and of course when there are injuries
it's very obvious and and they do
discuss that but yes the the long-term
effects now